youtube ist halt keine gemeinnützige
organisationen wie attac zum beispiel
obwohl sind wir ja auch nicht mehr ja
attac hat man gerade die
gemeinnützigkeit entzogen und es ihnen
dann ja echt sensibel mitgeteilt den
verein attac erreichen heute schlechte
nachrichten über das faxgerät und zu ein
urteil des bundesfinanzhofs die
mitarbeiter müssen dort lesen dass ihr
verein zu politischer giere und daher
die gemeinnützigkeit verliert ja per fax
ging nicht anders die rohrpost war
gerade verstorben aber jetzt mal im
ernst was hat attac den schlimmes
gemacht
attac hat sich tages politisch engagiert
hat tagespolitische forderungen
aufgestellt wie zum beispiel die
forderung nach einer
finanztransaktionssteuer
nein was getan
natürlich kann einem attac zu links sein
man kann auch bestimmte aktionen von
attac doofen aber für gerechtere
besteuerung von konzernen anzutreten ist
doch im grunde ja fast schon
gemeinnützig find ich echt bitter für
attac denn ihre unterstützer können
spenden nicht mehr von der steuer
absetzen
und weil das bei denen so prima geklappt
hat wie die union jetzt auch noch der
deutschen umwelthilfe so den hahn
abdrehen
ja die sind nämlich schuld an den
fahrverboten in unseren städten nicht
die autoindustrie die waren das wenn
dort ein abmahn verein das einzige ziel
verfolgt unsere städte laden zu legen
beim diesel dann müssen wir klartext
sprechen ein hobby trusted aus meine
damen und herren
foto laschet kann auch anders freunde
wie kann diese umwelthilfe mit ihren
fragen einfach geltendes recht
durchsetzen wo kommen wir denn da hin
weil immer wäre genau das nicht die
aufgabe von unserem verkehrsminister
wo ist der eigentlich
[Musik]
tschüss machen langes wochenende drauf
gerne drei jahre oder so kein problem ja
nochmal man kann die umwelthilfe und
attac kritisieren oder doofen aber zur
politischen willensbildung gehört schon
das lobbyverbände von allen seiten des
politischen spektrums einfluss haben und
nicht nur solche die autos bauen
bei anderen vereinen da frage ich mich
was hat denen bitte gemeinnützig sein
soll
der förderverein der initiative neue
soziale marktwirtschaft zum beispiel der
gerade heftig gegen die grundrente
trommeln oder kennen sie den
der sogenannte deutsche fußball-bund hat
uns allen wohl ein sommermärchen gekauft
knapp 300 millionen euro einnahmen pro
jahr aber die werden sehr sehr
gemeinnützig ausgegeben die einwöchige
reise des dfb präsidiums zum wm finale
2014 sollen mehr als 370.000 euro
gekostet haben
ja aber mit frühstück
und nutzen ja jetzt mal ehrlich ich kann
nur raten jetzt mal ehrlich der dfb
unter uns ist jetzt nicht so viel
gemeinnütziger als sagen wir mal der
abou chaker clan oder oder ich finde
schon aber zurück zu attac was genau ist
da eigentlich passiert ein mysteriöser
fall für unseren besten mann
privatdetektiv dennis kloster in der tod
kennt keine gemeinnützigkeit
[Musik]
ich war einer dieser unfassbaren tage in
meinem büro
ich wollte gerade schon vor langeweile
an mir rum spielen als mir einfiel dass
ich ja kundschaft habe die nervige einer
birne vom zdf
was wollt ihr denn noch mal
sie hatte ihm nicht zugehört richtig
harte attacke
da habe ich schlechte nachrichten für
sie welche die im linken spinnern hat
man nach meinen ermittlungen völlig zu
recht die gemeinnützigkeit entzogen
diese irren haben wiederholt gegen
steuervermeidung protestiert ihr nackt
vom kanzleramt und sie benutzt die
schlimmste waffen von allen einen
pantomimen
[Musik]
allein dafür gehören die schweine
erschossen klar jeder hasst pantomime
aber wer steckt denn jetzt hinter der
attacke auf attacke auch das konnte ich
herausfinden 2016 hat im streit um die
gemeinnützigkeit vor einem gericht in
kassel noch gewonnen aber dann hat sich
wohl jemand von ganz oben eingeschaltet
seine weisung hat dafür gesorgt dass der
fall vom bundesfinanzhof gelandet ist
ich kann die identität aus
datenschutzgründen leider nicht
preisgeben aber ich habe ein phantombild
das ist wolfgang schäuble ja aber das
haben sie nicht von mir
schäuble alias schwarz gelb wolle hatte
eine persönliche rechnung mit attac
offen weil die bekloppten immer wieder
öffentlich auf dem thema
steuervermeidung rumreiten stimmt unter
steinbrück und schäuble saß doch dieser
maulwurf vom bankenverband im
finanzministerium und hat an gesetzen
mit geschrieben die den comics vertrug
erst möglich gemacht haben
nicht einzelne akteure sondern ein
ganzes kriminelles netzwerk soll den
fiskus geprellt haben
und obwohl es immer wieder hinweise zur
betrugsmasche gab benötigte das
bundesfinanzministerium mehr als zehn
jahre für eine wirksame gesetzesänderung
das hat den deutschen steuerzahler 32
milliarden gekostet
also mich letztlich warum instinkt war
nicht dem finanzministerium die
gemeinnützigkeit klar entschuldigt ist
in der geschichte keiner und meistens
verraten sich die täter durch
körpersprache ja warum fassen sie sich
denn nicht an die eigene nase
es ist doch auch so
ja im nachhinein muss man sagen schade
dass attacke ein maulwurf im
finanzministerium eingeschleust hat wäre
billiger gewesen aber vergessen sie
anzag diese erledigt
unser staat nimmt sich jetzt alle
vereine vor die nerven
ich weiß sogar schon wen sie als
nächstes fertigmachen brot für die welt
man hat herausgefunden die verschenken
brot und zwei ganze welt ach du scheiße
aber nicht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]